got some rain thanks to monsoon storms
that happened over the weekend some of
our viewers sending in
this video a neighbor saw so much rain
streets were flooded in parts of
henderson
along with mountain's edge there are a
lot of projects that are going on around
the valley that
actually though help control this type
of flooding from getting out of control
but
that work is still ongoing it's not
quite done valley-wide
eight news now reporter sally jaramillo
visited some drainages and washes for a
look at how far we've come
and what we can expect in the future
sally denise yesterday's storms brought
so much rain to the southern highlands
park
a creek running really through this
walking trail aaron neff with the
regional flood control district says
there are signs all over that read
you are entering a dual use drainage
recreation facility this area is subject
to flash floods you are reminded to stay
away during stormy conditions since
there is still drainage issues
in this community nev says we've had two
straight years of nonsoon but this year
we are back
to normal habits although this is
typical for those who have lived in the
valley for years she says
many people are moving to southern
nevada and must be in form of the
dangers back in the 70s she recalls
dangerous flooding
in the caesars palace area and miracle
mile flooding
about 21 years ago and since the 1980s
they have built 667 miles of channels
and storm drains along with 102
detention basins
despite flooding diminishing there's
still work that needs to be done
so i can tell you in the next 10 years
we plan to spend
800 million dollars in flood control
to help improve more areas
particularly the fast growing areas of
the southwest
portions of henderson northwest las
vegas
all areas that are still booming in
growth
nephats they still have ways to go so
far they are at 75 percent finished with
their master planning and build out
neff also says they have plans to
install 75 more miles of channel
within the next 10 years now for now
reporting live in southern highlands
sally jaramillo
8 news now